[Applause]
did you know that nearly 80 billion
pounds of food is wasted every year in
the united states
and yet 35
million people in america including 10
million children are suffering from food
insecurity
so
what change is possible
well our next guest andrew gooder
shows that anyone can step up and take
action and she says that she has saved
five thousand dollars worth of food on a
daily basis daily
okay
and for the past 22 years she has done
this and she has no intention of
stopping so please everybody give a warm
welcome to my new hero the amazing paddy
pack
so excited to meet you i have been so
excited look at like
it just says it on my notes i love you
paddy peck
so i'm just going to tell you in person
because i've been waiting to say it to
you face to face um i would like you to
teach me
how you got involved in this mission
well one day i was grocery shopping in
my local town and uh i was going to the
service desk to ask the girl a question
and while i was standing there she
motioned to a young boy and said take
those three carts and throw them in the
dumpster they were beautiful cakes and
bread in packages and everything looked
so nice i said wait a minute you can
throw this stuff in the garbage i said
i'll run it up to the homeless shelter
at least somebody who can use it
and she said oh no there's laws about
that you can't take the food i said
listen could you give me the name of the
guy that runs this place because i was
so angry
she gave me the guy's name i went home i
called the guy and he was very receptive
and he said wow
he said so i said you know i don't
understand why you don't donate this
food if you're going to throw it in the
dumpster why not give it to an
organization that could use it he goes
why don't you and i said what do you
mean he goes well i have 11 stores
between here and there pick how many
stores you want and fax me your driver's
license and your and your car insurance
so existed in like 1981 faxing
1999. i started i'm old school so
you got my heart pumping with the fax
machine so i faxed him all my
information two days later he calls and
he goes okay you're all set for tomorrow
i said okay
i went home and i said what am i gonna
do with all this food so i got in the
yellow pages
the salvation army again the yellow
pages patty you're speaking my language
i'm old
no i love it
[Applause]
i called all the agencies that i saw in
the phone book so i said how would you
like to have a free food delivery one
day a week and everybody nobody said no
so i got a book a composition book there
we go oh i love i still have those too
okay and then i on each page i wrote
monday tuesday wednesday thursday and i
made like a root
i just
love you patty so
much you are just such an inspiration
now how did the pandemic affect you i
haven't i didn't miss one day in the
pandemic
not one day
thank you
i mean
patty i want you to rule the world
um you certainly are the matriarch of
your family i know you have
um you know a daughter and a grandson
who are your deepest joy
but they're in florida right now
um
have you seen them
it's been a month
um you know what um i think we're gonna
uh give you a little message from enzo
actually right now i'm going to share it
with you
hi graham you do so much for everyone
and i want to give you a big hug i'm the
luckiest kid to be your grandson and i
hope i get to see you soon love and soul
[Applause]
um patty um
may i ask how that makes you feel
i'm lost without him
he's my only grandson and my daughter's
my only child
so uh her and i were always really close
but he's just
made everything
wonderful my whole life
that's all it's about
you just do so much for other people
i mean you just take care of everyone
around you and because of that
we really want to give you five thousand
dollars to get to visit your grandson
thank you so much
thank you thank you so much
well patty i'd like to ask you what is
one thing that i could do
to take care of others better what's
your advice to me i don't know i think
you you already have the empathy i can
see that you know and you know to tell
you how i you know started this just a
couple of one quick story there was a
girl that i serve i have a bunch of
single parents so i got one girl that
has four children
and i pulled in her driveway and i was
bringing them food
and her little daughter was standing at
the top of the driveway hysterical
crying i said what's the matter honey
she goes mommy said if you didn't come
today we had to eat toast again for
dinner
and this is somebody that lives next
door to you see this is what i like to
tell people you know you don't know
what's going on in somebody else's house
okay and you know when you hear that
somebody lost their job or something
cook some brownies and bring them over
there you don't know what the situation
is you know what i'm saying right i got
the takeaway i love this thank you so
much
[Music]
you